recently the founder of stability AI
made an ominous prediction there are no
programmers in 5 years there are no
programmers in 5 years just 2 years ago
nobody was using AI code assistance but
2 years after GitHub co-pilot beta was
launched we're now here 41% of all code
on GitHub right now is AI generated
that's a crazy claim and I'd be highly
skeptical of it but I'd believe it next
year after looking at these crazy new
updates in GitHub co-pilot the launch of
Google's duet Ai and the launch of jet
brains AI all of which just happened in
the last few days it is December 14th
2023 and you're watching the code report
before we get into this video first a
disclaimer the tools we're about to look
at may make you want to drop out of your
computer science degree and switch your
major to Plumbing but that would be dumb
because they're also coming out with AI
powered smart toilets but more
importantly pessimism leads to weakness
optimism leads to power it's possible
programmers won't exist in 5 years but
it's also possible that programmers will
get paid five times as much in 5 years
because everyone got discouraged and
quit computer science in 2023 okay so
now that we have that optimism out of
the way what we're looking at today is
the next generation of AI tooling but as
of today that's all it is it's not
capable of replacing any human yet the
big announcement yesterday is that duet
AI from Google is now generally
available it can be installed into your
IDE and provides access to an AI chatbot
you can chat in a dedicated panel or get
inline suggestions and intellisense just
like Hub co-pilot but unlike co-pilot
it's totally free well at least until
next year before it becomes $19 per
month its real killer feature though is
its integration with Google Cloud it
allows you to link a cloud project and
then manage all the resources directly
from the IDE as well as access to
documentation and generate code samples
for your project and it's also worth
noting that Google's working on its own
cloud IDE based on VSS code called
project idx which is not only integrated
with this AI but also has things like
IOS and Android emulators built in that
run on a cloud VM so you don't have to
download and configure a bunch of sdks
now currently its underlying AI model is
not Gemini Ultra which is claimed to be
the best AI programmer out there if
that's true duet has the potential to be
a GitHub co-pilot killer in the future
but speaking of co-pilot Killers jet
brain also just announced their new
co-pilot killer in December it is
possible to use co-pilot in Jeet brains
idees but the experience has never been
that great it just feels like it gets in
the way more so than it does in vs code
the AI assistant feels much more natural
and well integrated and can do things
like chat refactoring write
documentation write unit tests offer
companionship generate commit messages
and so on but with a price tag of $10
per month it costs nearly as much as the
IDE itself and the initial reviews are
fairly mixed what's interesting though
is that it's powered by something called
Jeet brains AI service and this allows
the chatbot to be powered by multiple
different models there's not a ton of
detail around this but it's an extremely
powerful idea with co-pilot and duet you
have GPT 4 and Gemini but with jet
brains you could hypothetically hook up
your own fine-tune model like maybe the
open source code Llama Or mistol canbin
with the billions of lines of code at
your company allowing the AI to provide
predictable responses based on your
coding conventions that's pretty cool
but at the same time GitHub co-pilot
just leveled up big time previously it
was based on GPT 3.5 but now it's using
GPT 4 it now has a dedicated chat window
so you basically have chat GPT in your
IDE but what's really amazing is that it
has this workspace command that allows
you to search all the code files in your
workspace to write code with the proper
context in your project so far I've
actually found it most useful for
explaining code When jumping into an
unfamiliar project in other words it
makes it way easier to figure out what
the hell is going on with this guy's
spaghetti code it also now writes your
commit messages and is also available in
the terminal to explain and refactor
commands but there's one big problem
with these AI tools sometimes they spit
out suggest sus from code and repos that
you're not allowed to use and I really
can't go back to jail but luckily
co-pilot will now search across billions
of files in GitHub and will return the
licenses on any similar code and that
means you can be relatively confident
that you're not stealing someone's code
well I mean you are stealing it but
you're allowed to overall these changes
are pretty amazing and extremely useful
these tools still can't build complex
projects out of nowhere but the big
question is where are we going from here
currently co-pilot doesn't run your code
or create new files but I think we're
going there eventually like you might be
able to just take your client's
requirements and say say hey build this
thing in Django then co-pilot will run
the commands create the files and run
the unit tests required to make that a
reality then you'll continue fine-tuning
it with multiple shots or prompts until
it builds exactly what you're looking
for without ever touching a line of code
another missing piece is image data
there are already tools that can convert
a screenshot into code and as these
tools get better we'll likely see them
integrated directly in the IDE now even
if this stuff does get really good I
wouldn't be discouraged as a programmer
right now is one hell of a time to be
alive code is just a means to an end
even if programming becomes obsolete
there will still be Engineers pushing
the limits of whatever comes next like
we still need to develop robots brain
chips quantum computers euthanasia pods
laser guns space travel time travel and
all sorts of other sci-fi and
it's going to take some good
old-fashioned problemsolving Engineers
to do that so stay optimistic this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one